but we're going to begin of course in
Florida again where there is widespread
Devastation and loss today in the wake
of hurricane Ian many of the beach
communities along the state's Gulf Coast
are disaster zones this morning
President Biden pierces could be
Florida's deadliest storm ever
unfortunately this system is not done
yet what had been tropical storm Ian has
now strengthened once again to a
hurricane it could hit South Carolina
just hours from now our lead National
correspondent David begnos in Fort Myers
where people are still struggling yeah
they've been having a rough go of it
David and now we don't want to hear
hurricane returns good morning to you
good morning to you as the sun is
starting to rise we yet again are taking
a look at just a widespread destruction
Gail we are in the heart of Fort Myers
right along the caloosahatchee river
behind me you've got boats that are
really just tossed like toys into and on
top of each other the recovery effort's
going to take a long time and no doubt
be very very expensive homes were just
ripped from their foundations I mean
people are homeless this morning A lot
of people are in shelters others have
driven for hours looking for hotels in a
lot of places the high water is started
to recede and that's really giving us
the best look yet at the destruction
emergency responders from the Coast
Guard the National Guard and other
search and rescue teams have conducted
at least 700 rescues so far there have
been reports of at least four deaths but
that number is no doubt expected to rise
at 911 centers in Southwest Florida have
really been overwhelmed with thousands
of people who say I'm stranded I need
you to come and get me out of my own
house I'm in my attic I'm on my roof
we're talking about life-threatening
emergencies here the best way to see how
devastating this storm was is to see
what it looked like before Ian here's a
look at the shoreline and the pier in
Fort Myers before the storm
and here it is after the pier stripped
businesses reduced to Rubble I mean it's
really a common sight along this stretch
of the southwestern Coast of Florida
we got in a helicopter yesterday to
really get an up close look at the
devastation here's what we saw
some of these holes right there look at
that I mean that home is just flat
pretty quickly after we took off the
scope of the devastation really came
into Focus from the air home after home
block after block seemingly
neighborhoods torn apart by Hurricane
Ian this is little Hickory Island near
Bonita Shores and it's incredible
because you don't know where the streets
are the sand has come in from the ocean
and covered it to the point where it's
caked there are vehicles and homes that
are literally in the tree line there
from the air we got a good sense of just
how widespread the destruction was along
the coast and Inland it was as if this
hurricane just grabbed the Earth and
shook it tossing things like toys in a
bathtub for Sanibel Island but we
couldn't
hit by the FAA
in order to get
rest on Motors out
we got off the helicopter at a high
school field and not long after in the
exact same spot our producer notices
another helicopter coming into land it's
a coast guard chopper with the
straighter family taken to safety after
being stuck on Sanibel Island for two
days the only Road in and out the
causeway was ripped apart by the storm
surge everything on Sanibel is destroyed
that's for sure it was about an hour
where the wind was coming pretty hard I
was praying a lot a lot a lot Patrick
and Rebecca Strader needed to be rescued
after they stayed behind with their two
kids Grant and Nora Sanibel is now
practically a No Man's Land we asked the
straighters why they decided to stay
behind they had just purchased a home on
the island two weeks ago and they were
in a rental property as they got ready
to move in the family says the storm
surge rushed in Rising quickly the house
was vibrating they told us pictures
literally falling off the walls as the
water Rose around them when the water
came in it came fast though yeah that's
the part it would have been fine because
we're from Fort Lauderdale we know a
normal hurricane
when the surge came through that was
when I was freaking out there was quite
a few homes in the neighborhood that
were not as lucky there were one
collapsed
um the roofs were gone
the straighters nervous themselves did
their best to keep the kids calm and
distracted for as long as they could our
iPads died and we didn't have any
electricity so last night they slept in
a hotel as to what's next seven-year-old
Nora has an idea I want to go to New
Hampshire
we're going anywhere not far away from
an island
the straighters still don't know if
their home was destroyed the one they
were waiting to move into as for the
reason they stayed on the island take a
look they gave us pictures they had pets
they couldn't be moved 90 pound
tortoises that have been a part of
Patrick's family for more than two
decades but in the end the tortoises did
not survive the storm
you know it's not just homes that were
destroyed by Hurricane Ian here in Fort
Myers you've got critical infrastructure
that was really devastated along
Florida's West Coast I'm talking water
plants the power grid and essential
services